hello everybody my name is will I don't
know what happened to me very strange so
I'm caught in my lungs hello everybody
my name is markiplier and welcome back
to three scary games lots of spooky
stuff coming up lots of spooky stuff to
the left right up behind you behind me
lots of scary stuff okay so we're gonna
start off with a game called Graham
Graham are you back there in the
darkness Journal that's tiny it's been a
long time since I've entered Grandma's
house
Lilly my sister she stayed well I kind
of left her there I had no choice
grandma isn't a saint that's for sure
mom just left us with Grandma because
well she couldn't take care of us
I looked after Lilly for a long time
along as two words since then but it's
hard when grandma just want us to do
chores all the time that old bag hates
us she could care little care less to
words about Lilly and me grandma is
always hitting Lilly for no reason I've
tried to stop her but grandma would whip
me with the stick
not a stick the stick but grandma died
10 years ago huh and Lilly stayed there
at the house ever since then I don't
think Lilly is right in the head but I
have to go to her the voicemail I heard
wasn't anything like her from Mama Maura
nah I don't hello alright whatever let's
do this whoa
whoa I got a call from my sister
something's wrong Shh
[Music]
I have to I got no choice oh okay
we're in grandma's house now left-click
the open letters left click on dressers
to open drawers M main menu left click
on recorder to interact how to play
explore the house teddy is your guide
Teddy wait ok Teddy I'm slow who is this
dear diary I feel trapped in this house
I can't leave here no matter how hard I
try the demons I sometimes see before I
sleep have taken a shadow form I can
hear the whispers they speak within the
walls and under my bed love Lily ok cool
Lily I'm beginning to think that maybe
you were the cause of this problem and
maybe you shouldn't have been so obtuse
in your gabbling with forces beyond your
comprehension that's what I'm beginning
to think I feel like I've played a game
like this before like it said I had
never played this before but this really
seems like something I played before the
recorder is different but maybe this is
because a lot of these games sometimes
use the same assets hello wait this
looks so familiar dear diary grandma's
been shoving red meat down my throat she
said I need to stay alive until the
moments right why is she doing this to
me what moment my fingertips are so sore
from being pricked grandma's sadistic
ways are getting worse she smiles at me
saying eat up dear wouldn't want that
fine meat to go to waste
ok very strange ok
alright have I played this by getting
vibes I'm getting vibe oh that looks so
familiar the notes seem different is
this like an updated version of a game
dear diary grandma is dead I'm not sure
what happened she was in her room
hanging by a rope her neck must have
strass snapped as soon as she kicked the
chair inside me I felt something was
bound to happen soon something that told
me death was coming the voices in my
head will not go away they whisper
Maria's name I have to finish what
grandma started
what did grandma start wait what are you
talking about what wait wait wait a
minute what did grandma start okay
maybe it's just like this house is like
a prefab that's been built before and
it's a different game using Abbi oh this
is your hell oh okay well that's good to
know
what's my heaven then what are you gonna
say is my heaven yeah come on don't be
shy now says you me and the ghost in the
walls it's all good here I do
oh you're open great all right look
that's fine that's fine that's totally
fine
Oh Teddy be my guide okay that's
definitely a different game Teddy oh
okay this is for real spooky okay okay
this is legit spook time okay that's a
nice clock yeah I don't need to go there
that's nice clock I think that'll fit in
my pocket [ __ ] who we're open okay this
is legit spooky okay I was
is happy that me that might be me Lily
which is very appropriate for how
someone would call out to the darkness
hi grandma okay sure marina I know one
day you will read these pages from my
diary so I've scattered them throughout
the house so you can remember why didn't
you just leave the diary intact at the
front door
why did you scatter them that's the most
asinine thing I've ever heard why would
you do that that's just backwards
whatever fine Lily's not right in that
see remember your reason for leaving me
to rot my hatred towards you has grown
throughout the years that's one word I
can never forgive you
teddy be my guide okay is this saying I
need to go right because left will kill
me let's go left then right well that
doesn't bode good Lee at all oh I was
thinking that something was gonna come
out to jump at me I was a lass
[Music]
what mmm sounds no good please don't do
that again okay none of these work why
are you trying to pull here bear berries
gone oh oh hi bear be my guide I'll be
your guest okay weird so um yeah
I cannot tell where that came from oh it
came from here okay good great yeah hi
um I'm here now grandma are you here to
knock twice on the walls if you are show
up in a mirror suddenly if you aren't
that's not a book I can interact with
okay cool cool how about this before
oh no no no way no way no way no how
this is different very different
this is so bizarre because I'm getting a
feeling of deja vu but things are
different like some things aren't it
might be an updated version of a game I
haven't played in a while
oh that's cool hey how you doing you
didn't quite finish your song there but
you know it's so beautiful I got all of
it when I needed to get it okay good
thanks for having me here I'm just gonna
oh wow
not the teddy bear no yeah I don't
remember that but I remember a
jump-scare being there but well that's
not a good sign but you hate to see that
Oh bear you're back hey Bob how you
doing hey good to see you okay all right
oh great ah candles oh let's get it
Moody up in here wait if those crosses
turn upside down I have played this
before then are you have hello everybody
my name is markiplier and welcome to
grandma I have played this before then
that chairs gonna rise up into the air
saved by the angel tortured by the devil
freedom awaits in the images of evil
those those crosses are gonna turn up I
knew it
hey ho
save me help
I think this is just oh hi grandma
Oh grandpa grandma Grammy Griff oh yeah
this is an updated version of that game
whoo-hoo and it's spookier I'm all about
that okay all right
well grandma ah you've looked better
I will say that you've given Lily all
the meat when it is very clear you need
to put some meat on your bones so yeah
there is that all right well I expected
that to lock being here it said
something about drawers but it doesn't
seem like I can actually open any
journal dear journal I'm completely
alone I went to tell Maria everything
last night but she wasn't in her bed in
the window was left open I'm alone Maria
left me here she abandoned me I did all
this for her I did what I was told so
she could be protected okay well Maria
that's that's a dick move the toolbar
the souls of old-world
yeah
Suz whoa all right well that room was
fun and the whole orchestra in there and
everything oh hell oh okay well uh don't
mind if I do
skip the blue you're still dad all right
good good to hear good oh I can actually
open things now wait wait wait no way
what nah am i doing that wait now I
can't do it anymore
there we go okay that's bizarre hmm so I
can't open drawers but only kind of only
a little bit okay anything different out
here still hell okay good oh hi ooh
that's right there's like a second part
of this ordeal hello Lily you still mad
at me Lily dear journal something's
really wrong with Lily she's taking it
to herself and when she looks at me she
reacts as if I'm some kind of ghost so
try to touch me to make sure I'm
actually standing in front of her I
asked grandma if she noticed what was
happening to Lily but she just laughs
and gives me this feeling like something
dark has taken over Lily well all right
then it's probably fine hi Oh
[Music]
what do you what do you mumbling about
humming a hibbity bibbity bibbity a
southerner bibbidi-bobbidi about a baby
deer whoo hi yeah this is cool though
like this is worth playing cuz it is
just an updated version but I like that
they updated it it's been so long since
the last one it's been like three years
maybe since I last played this I can't
leave here grandma says no one wants me
no one loves me my only purpose to feed
her demons she's right
while I leave when I have a purpose here
the pain is feeling numb or am i feeling
numb what do I feel Maria left me
because she doesn't love me well uh
something tells me maybe that's not so
true I remember last time I played this
I got lost in this hallway but no longer
this game was actually put into a
reaction compilation if I recall yeah oh
[Music]
oh I can do that too
we see you yeah well I hear you yell
loud bastards this games fun because it
feels like a haunted house like a like a
real-life haunted house you go in
different rooms you get different spooks
kind of cool actually I like it Ouija
board I need to find the planchette mm
thing to remember something about that
oh planchette ooh way knock-knock
planchette where would there be a
planchette hmmm planchette planchette i
can't open any other drawer I'm guessing
the planchette must be in here err maybe
this was Lily's room that's where Enzo
is so maybe
oh-oh-oh we're open we're here oh great
okay beautiful singing voice Lily truly
something to behold planchette come on
tell me the joke oh come on tell it to
me I'm already laughing we're all
laughing it I'm laughing you laughing
the monster behind you is laughing we're
all laughing maybe I shouldn't have done
this
there's gonna be writing on the walls if
I remember this right ooh
oh maybe I should have closed the door
[Music]
Rambow
okay you know what never mind you're
fine Loulou
[Music]
yes spooky hey are you doing no no no no
okay all right cool good great good talk
Thanks you need any help
oh she's not real okay hey can I go now
oh hi
this looks final like a finale awesome
kind
I mean nothing really stopped me oh hi
uh all right
the sacrifice has begun is it me that's
being sacrificed to a mine this
sacrifice odd for Peru oh wow oh oh I
can't
how do I turn Oh teddy wait wait Teddy
help Teddy Teddy what did I what did I
do
oh thanks teddy
I'm sure you extinguish the fire with
your body made of pure specced as' and
love oh my god
something tells me that would be fatal
um you yeah you're right lilz stop being
so melodramatic what I'm sorry you run
that by me again
shabba-doo boo boo boo ha bobbidi boo
okay alright I guess I'm just looking to
leave well that's enough for me I'm
checking out see you around the bend the
littles okay great mmm grandma
that's my name don't wear it out no no
weird either year going okay okay oh my
boobs wait what the [ __ ] oh oh okay I
see
Oh
uh okay I'm gonna get I hear cuz very
loud okay so that was grandma
I have played grandma before 2017 did
seem like the year but much improved
still like just a wander around in a
haunted house I'm gonna laugh if like
it's exactly the same as it was and I
just stupid don't remember right but
yeah so that was grandma not bad good
little blast from this alright
alright so this one's called the night
is long also the rain is loud whoo oh
that's a cool loading screen by the way
Oh cutscene oh hell yeah
[ __ ] piece of garbage I knew I should
have sold you when I had the chance
let's see what it is around here let's
see what it is what is that there
I can fly let go check it out let go Oh
on Friday night Ryan decided to go away
on vacation on his way a nasty
thunderstorm hit the area he was driving
through it was late at night when
suddenly his car stopped running he
started the engine again with no luck
[ __ ] now what he thought to himself he
went out and looked around he had no
idea what to do and he couldn't see
anything nearby he did the first thing
that came to his mind he got a
flashlight that he kept in the car for
emergencies and randomly chose the
direction to follow and find help after
a few minutes walking he found himself
in front of a mansion it seems abandoned
he thought he had no other choice but to
check it out and wait for the storm to
pass this is gonna be a long night he
thought is the end of the building he
had no idea he felt it was no
coincidence that he felt him found
himself in this situation It was as if
something or someone had led him there
for some reason he just could not put
his finger upon it yet alright cool good
great sounds good man sounds good ah ba
ba ba ba just eat read this is the story
of my life I was once happy and I had
everything I wanted I guess nothing good
lasts forever that is actually a great
3/3 sentence story that's not bad I
actually like that
key the door okay
Oh was that a spider that crawled up my
vision Oh what oh that's weird there was
like some Doppler effect on that thing
huh interesting
ooh we've got an open thing the the
movements a little clunky but it's okay
I meant the love of my life a long time
ago on the way to town she and I talked
for hours and she always made me feel
good about myself years passed before I
finally asked the important question I
was nervous that is a spider on my
eyeball
you scared the spider away
that's a weird wait what did I just get
okay I got a key okay what did I get a
key to the reason the walking is clunky
is because it keeps going after I stop
for another step it's like he's got a
complete his stride as if he has free
will doesn't mean oh my he's my puppet
to do with as I get out of your ghost
get out of here you nerd stupid nerd
ghost we had been together for years
when she said there was something
important she had to tell me I had no
idea what it could be
I waited impatiently till she came back
from a regular outing in the evening she
came back as soon as we sat as a dinner
table she informed me that soon I would
be a father that is not the news I was
expecting that's good I think okay oh
this one hello
perfect
oh well hi I didn't make sure I didn't
expect anything to actually be there do
I closer to I'm a closest or Thanks
that's good
oh no thanks
great good great solved that one
successfully navigated that nightmare
good stuff good stuff a few months later
and there it was a small baby do you
know how long babies need to be made
it's not a few months it's quite a few
anyway a small baby in my hands was the
best thing that had happened in my life
okay the second-best thing but still I
can't wait to see what the future holds
for all of us there goes that spider
likes to jump into my eye just gonna go
across the hall now everything's fine no
problems here great
even better was I supposed to go
upstairs I'll go upstairs you know what
I'll go upstairs it's all good the night
is long after all okay well moonwalk
away why don't you you think you can
scare me with a moonwalk just because I
don't understand how it works doesn't
mean that you can scare me oh my eyes
all right well that was eventful Thanks
okay one day my wife came back from her
shopping and didn't feel well I told her
to lie down and rest I made something to
eat and drink fur I was worried about
her the doctors did not know what was
wrong there was one thing in my head
that I was afraid of I didn't want to
think about it
doctors had no idea except that they
knew exactly what it was
that's a weird curtain anything in the
tub scrub-a-dub-dub there is an
apparition and I'm scared and don't know
what to do I hear something who would is
it who is it could it be are my eyes
deceiving me is what I are see really
her
Edwyn Oh how would I know I'm a figment
of your imagination for all you know I
don't even exist
maybe I've been the ghost all along no
nap hmm
sure is a puzzle you know a plus for
effort you know that was that was really
something that was something oh the
opposite bathroom my worst fears came
true today as my wife unfortunately
passed away I was devastated by this and
I did not know what to do at least I had
my daughter and she's the only thing I
have now I will try to be strong for her
and you will fail miserably oh hi yeah
your wife lovely lovely lady she's a
real beaut a real looker
that's stunner even I don't have any
more keys I didn't get it
was I supposed to get another key was
there something in the water do I gonna
reach in to your wife's bathwater that
you've kept there we go
she pushed it out get you hello yo incus
who was that well it'd be great if I
could actually know what that was why
why tell me why what did I do to deserve
this tell me I was talking to myself and
as that as I saw my family falling sick
and passing away in front of my eyes
they both became infected by a deadly
virus why was I spared why why don't you
God hello hi
what should I do I have nothing left to
live for I shut myself in the mansion
alone with my thoughts I started to walk
around the mansion aimlessly exploring
the secrets of this mansion
I guess I hoped that I would find
something to fill the void in my heart
the pastor's led me into a library where
I could see some weird stones it looked
like a ceremonial place I started to
examine the places immediately as they
didn't have anything else to do anyway
oh boy you shall not escape
oh really lady
it's a false mirror oops I'm sorry I'm
I'm sorry
and these spiders in my eyes make me see
things hello while reading books that
late about I discovered something
interesting something that could change
everything
this is puzzle oh okay okay
I I'm not good at these typically so
don't expect any magic to happen no this
is on completely the wrong side this
needs to be down there okay I don't know
why but my brain has never been able to
do these properly okay there we go got
it okay good yeah yeah that's pretty
spooky you are a distract distance noise
a distance noise I hear a distance noise
from down east easy well better go check
that out first before I do any more I
might not get the true ending it may
seem like I'm mocking this it actually
is like it pretty interesting so it's a
pretty interesting game I'm actually
kind of into it I mean it's a little
clunky and obviously not refined but you
know it shows that there's effort into
this and I gotta like it okay well there
was nothing in there
what about in here bedroom you say oh oh
baby bed oh I can't believe my eyes it
is her finally I will be reunited with
my family once again yes my love it is
me we found each other again even death
cannot separate us well yeah I'm sure
that's that's that's that's what's
happening you yeah it's all good it's
all good my man was that the only thing
that happened down here or am I free to
go maybe hello what's in here
way okay you got me that time you got me
that time I'll get you a puzzle I found
on da floor unlocked secret passage
curious where it could lead
secret passage but I did that but I
already did that there was something
about the arcade there's got to be a
secret passage downstairs then I where
is this secret passage come on show to
me oh this was not oh okay
what's going on is this a big mistake I
can't think straight anymore the voices
make them stop I can't focus because
they're so loud I'm sorry I just wanted
to see you again yeah not bad not bad
it's uh it's really rough at the same
time it is actually not bad I think the
game is not polished it's very basic
it's very much just like a to be find
the key and the story is is not very
related to the person who's there but at
the same time you know just determine
observational capacity it's got some
potential so keep working whoever made
this keep working on it keep making
games like they'll get better every time
and this is not a bad place to start but
time for us to move on this one is
called trapped why are we trapped I
don't know where are we trapped I don't
know skin wait for bones my skin does
weigh about four bones that sounds about
right
start it's supposed to be like a found
footage style horror game whoa it is
like found footage oh I'm going
backwards baby you can't stop me that's
a bone here I go oh this was the bad but
it's to go oh my okay I didn't mean to
come down into the body tunnel right
away what the hell well uh made a mint
mint maybe down here forever now
that's okay worse things have happened
maybe very out last but yeah what is
happening who is pooping on me
don't flush please don't flush who I
should oh god oh god oh god oh okay on
August 17 1997 a cannibalistic creature
known as Krypton cryptozoology as a
skinwalker was shot and killed in the
sewer system after police discovered
multiple bodies in the area the found
footage indicated the person filming did
not survive the incident the tunnels
have been closed and sealed the
knowledge of the event has been kept out
of the public's view due to its
disturbing nature great good alright
well that was spooky I don't know if I
was supposed to go down that way I
really don't um let's try it again I
don't even know why I'm here why am I
here what did I do to deserve this
alright let's try this again let's try
to get the good ending of not dying okay
so long as I don't fall down I'm sure
I'll be fine
oh no it's dead end here isn't it it's
gonna be vanished all over again I can
actually run here I'm speedy
where am I going hi rat hey dude good to
see you
good to see you brick wall great love it
hi who's there kinda spooky
oh okay that came out of nowhere I'm not
gonna lie it's kind of spooky spooky in
these tunnels I'm guessing the thing is
like if you happen to drop down you're
gonna die no matter what but apparently
I'm gonna die anyway don't know what the
point is zooming it it is doesn't help
you oh [ __ ] we're fine it's all good
baby
so good this does not look like what I
was just going through but okay
apparently it was I don't like it why
why why why what is happening what is
happening what's happening what's
happening what's happening am i winning
oh my [ __ ] god okay why did that one
not end in an ending the hell okay so
that thing is just there no clues that
it's gonna arrive other than just BAM
Wow
Here I am alright sure you know we're
gonna go with that I'm just gonna gun it
I'm sure there is a way out of here you
just have to get to it and I don't think
it's random it's gotta just be a path
out right
heard that whistling oh well whatever
man with knife Jesus Christmas says it's
a person down there with a knife why
didn't he kill me how many people are in
this sewer hell I got I'm gonna try to
make my way back to whatever that was I
think I walked over someone who is
sleeping or something is that what I did
- bang - baby hello there oh are you
gonna give me okay all right
God around him didn't know that was a
thing that could happen
oh is it locked it would be wouldn't it
well I found the door so where would a
key be where would that it is like
vanished all over again this is
straight-up vanish okay so that's the
thing there am I supposed to be worried
about those noises or is that not a
problem sure he's quiet oh I can't go
through there of course blind why would
I be able to wait
wait that's lower hang on oh I've got an
even lower Crouch which is great
hi hi yeah hey how you doing
good to see you good to see it good oh
wow
oh oh my oh my Wow okay
is there something oh oh okay okay what
happened I don't know what happened I
don't know if I should be careful about
something in front of me or not
it's the same thing okay so this is like
an escape right that's what this is
supposed to be some kind of an escape so
that if something is chasing me I have a
way out right it's the only thing I can
imagine this is for you use oh I got the
power juice flowing boss don't worry all
the powers are all juiced up PI's fall
to the pipes real good electricity pipes
you know how works boss I'm just a man
locked me the key of course I need a key
how many keys are in here how many keys
do I need how many keys could one man
possibly need so I don't know if
something's chasing me in these tunnels
but those lights didn't help at all by
the way they didn't help none there are
none help exactly zero zero help oh how
are you ever ever supposed to know that
that thing's skatin on giorgia that's
impossible that is impossible there's no
way they'd have to have the reflexes of
a god alright so I would love to keep
doing this but unfortunately I am out of
time I got one of the endings apparently
I fell in the hole and then I died now
with good ending I was a bad anybody
that's okay anyway I don't have enough
time to finish this but that will do for
three scary games today thank you
everybody so much for watching if you
want to play these games for yourselves
remember they are linked in the
description below you just gotta click
read more and you'll see a whole bunch
of stuff including more scary games that
I played in pest the entire playlist is
down there the scary games playlist
check it out for yourselves subscribe
for more if you want or not if you're
uncool yeah that's not true maybe a the
way thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you
[Music]